all right
welcome to our career webinar how to
develop a machine
learning career our speaker today is
ronald van loon the ceo of intelligent
world
and an advisory board member here at
simply learn
and our session today is co-sponsored by
freshers world a team lease company
and before we get into the webinar
i would like to share with you a few
controls for the webex
system please enter your questions for
ronald
into the q and a box we will be
tracking those and queuing them up for
the q a toward the end of the session
um if you do put anything in the chat
box make sure you address it
to all panelists so that he can see it
as well as i
and then um we will be
logging some of the questions from there
as well but um
again the q a box is the proper place
for questions
and we will also be doing several polls
during
this session to ask your input
the first poll i'd like to do right now
which is
two questions what is your current job
role
and how are you feeling today
we've been asking this since the
beginning of the pandemic
to make sure the people who are working
in isolation are holding up well
and um we we're interested to know if
you're
a student if you're already working in
data science data engineering
uh if you're in management or in an
executive position
or if you're working um as a
professional in an other area
about 10 seconds left on the poll
and if you are watching on youtube live
or linkedin you can put your
answers in the comments and
let us share the poll results
so the distribution is
uh mainly students
or people in other areas
with a few managers and executives not
many people who are already working in
data
science and that's not necessarily
surprising because this is
about how to get into a data science
in an ai related area
and the good thing is that almost
everybody
is doing well or in the middle
we hope that the information this
webinar will help the people who are
not feeling us as well
with something that they can use in
their careers so let's go on
and i will introduce ronald as i
mentioned ronald
is the ceo of intelligent world he's one
of the foremost
thought leaders in data science and
digital transformation
you'll see if you look into the
these areas you'll see his name
mentioned frequently
um the number one influencer in data and
analytics
automation in the future for the tech
economy
as named by analytica
and he is uh an author on a number of
big data and data science
sites many articles and
web columns and again an
advisory board member here at simply
learn um
we rely on him heavily and we thank him
for being here today for this
session hi ronald hi it's a pleasure to
be here again
and i wanted to talk about
machine learning and why it's an
important field
so let's start with the definition what
is a machine learning engineer
thank you stuart for for the kind
introduction and um i see most people
are feeling well
and as you mentioned a few not but let's
make them feel well
and maybe first give a little bit an in
explanation why it is such an important
topic
and why we can have this discussion
today so i think
the discussion is really relevant in
today's climate for for quite some
reasons so on one hand
we see that technology adoption has
really skyrocketed
and advancement in this area has created
a more dynamic business landscape than
we have ever seen before and businesses
need
ai and they need machine learning to
thrive and
also they needed to innovate and to
create a competitive advantage and
especially now in this digital world
and especially where everything happens
remotely
and then without your right talent these
organizations they can't implement ai
and they can't
implement machine learning technologies
or achieve success
with their ai and machine learning
projects so many organizations
are facing quite some various maybe even
huge barriers with
deploying their ai systems and their
projects so one of the biggest
set setbacks for these companies are
currently experiencing is the lack of
specialized ai and machine learning
talent and i think that's
where you should become happy from if
you look to
what kind of demands there is for
machine learning engineers
and i collected some some statistics and
23 percent of the mature ai adopters
reported that they have
been a major or extreme gap between
their ai needs
and their current abilities and that was
a research from deloitte
and some other statistics 90 percent of
3500 surveyed business leaders across
the u.s
they said that the lack of skilled
people was
a major barrier to ai and i think this
reinforces the persistence of the talon
gap
and this is an issue not only in in
exclusive in the u.s it's in europe it's
in in asia it's globally and
23 percent of the organization attribute
ai and machine learning specialization
shortages as a main barrier
to their ai capabilities and to their ai
initiatives
and executives are even now more
concerned about moving to
too fast with with their ai investments
because
this is the main main challenge so
specific skill sets are necessary to
develop machine learning algorithms to
develop the models and top technology
companies in particular are looking for
acquiring machine learning engineers in
order to push the transformation
in their algorithm developed
some other statistics 94 of the job
postings
that focus on ai machine and terminology
over the last year specifically
target machine learning engineers so
this indicates that organizations today
deeply understand the impact and the
potential of machine learning
and if we then look to some some
financial statistics the worldwide
economy will gain
almost 16 trillion in revenue based upon
ai and machine learning developments
if we move towards 20 30. so
i think if you're not happy right now
you can become happy because this is a
direction
where you fee really for yeah should
feel safe
and i think individuals who are
interested in a career in machine
learning engineer will be able to
enjoy job security in this thing
exciting field
um and i think next to that there are
numerous
options where your career path could
could take you for
aspiring machine learning engineers or
those who are potentially interested in
exploring a career
as an option or data science
professionals who are seeking to
to enhance their existing job role um
and i think
today's conversation is going to be both
practical but also helpful
and then of course is the question um
what is a machine learning
engineer and why is it so popular um if
we look more from from a different
definition perspective if we look to a
machine
learning engineer is more a
software-focused position that
involves evaluating it involves
organizing but also monitoring data sets
and it involves
building models it involves improving
machine learning systems
so basically they develop and they
manage platforms
for machine learning projects and
there's a research firm gartner
very very well respected research firm
that described this role as in
ensuring that ai platforms deliver
against
the technical and the business
requirements
and so it's quite important role
and the role has some kind of evolved
out of combination of two roles
so one and we have a software engineer
and the other hand we have the data
scientist
so software engineers code and scale
programs and they developed the software
systems for an organization
and the data scientists they are
analytically focused
and they work with big data and they
help translate the data into action for
business now a machine learning engineer
can utilize
both of the skill sets so you can think
of them as
some kind of a mix between a data
scientist and
from an i.t perspective and ensuring
their machine learning models to run
properly in production
so machine learning engineers they are
allowing different industries
to to leverage the power of intelligent
disruptive technologies as
as this factors into the demand level
for this type of role
but on the other hand i think and i must
say
it's um it's quite complex um
they have to deploy and manage machine
learning models that process and
continuously learn from
these massive diverse quantities of data
um
they have to turn applications into
production to realize business value
but also maintaining the compliance
within the organization with the
governance
protocols and governance is really
critical for organizations so it's maybe
not the first thing that that you think
about but
but it's really really critical so it's
important to keep in mind that machine
engineering is still considered to be
some kind of new role some kind of
emerging role
um and that is not really totally
defined so it can move into
different directions as well um and they
are
at the intersection of i think three
disciplines
you can think about the devops
discipline which targets infrastructure
and processes required to scale
application of
operalization you can think about
data science where theoretically models
for driving machine learning
are developed and on the other hand i
think you can think about
software engineering and this focuses on
the scaling the accurate code
that machine learning programs run on
so it can often be maybe a little bit of
confusing to distinguish the rules
between
the difference from the different from
each other's if we look to job listings
for example
and they sometimes make it confusing
because there's so many
overlapping descriptions of job
responsibilities or
blurring across different roles like
data scientists data engineer machine
learning engineer
and on the other hand if we look to
larger companies and especially tech
companies
they're more likely to understand the
distinction across the rules and they
have the need
for very specialized roles like machine
learning engineer
so you often find a few data scientists
working at smaller companies and
assuming
numerous functions that often
more blend into more software machine
learning engineering roles
but let's break it down with some
differences in the roles so if we look
to machine learning
engineering requires software and
developer experience
as well as mathematics and software
engineering is going to be
a central focus of of this field
as opposed to the data engineering and
the business analysis and the research
intensive work
so this involves automation or real-time
apis for example which we delve into a
little bit later
then machine learning engineers they
don't just
build models they also work on the
software that runs those models
then we have the data scientists on the
other end
they perform data analysis with a b
testing with
leading strategies and leading
initiatives and focus on communication
to the rest of the organization
then we have for example data architects
they create more
analytic applications and streamline
data solutions
another role is for example data
engineers and they work
heavily with data they streamline data
pipelines they manage databases and they
help with gathering and storing the
real-time data
and of course there's many different
data science and related fields that we
can use as examples but i think the
bottom line is
your role as a machine learning engineer
will evolve
programming and software engineering
that have to do strictly
with machine learning systems and
becoming a machine learning engineer
i think is a popular and a growing field
of interest
and they're highly sought across all the
different industries so it's not only
the tech industries which makes it even
more interesting
because you can pick between a lot of
different roles and different
opportunities
and different industries and even in
this age of remote and hybrid work
i think the engineering skills are even
further growing in demand because of the
technology experts and the digital
skills
they are needed more than ever
and this is further i think accelerated
by the increasing need for machine
learning and ai related specialist in
the workforce
and i think on top of this popularity
becoming a machine learning engineers
has its perks because it's one
of the highest paid jobs in data science
related fields compared to any other
type of jobs we mentioned
next let's say to a data scientist and
to give you an id
in the us they pay around 150
000 annually for a machine learning
engineer
so these are substantial amounts and i
think um
if you you really dive into this
direction um
you're secured for for your future and
you can earn
nicely and next to that i think you can
live well from from the money as well so
um this makes it i think a highly
competitive job role so
stuart i hope i give a little bit of of
an id
from what it is and and why it is so
so increasingly popular which was this
slide
yeah yeah um
and that's a great overview um and
as you said it's it's one of the
the things that's as an emerging
technology it's a bit mysterious to a
lot of people who aren't
in the field that mystery
always translates into
high salaries because people
view it as such a
specialized skill and requiring
you know such uh detailed knowledge
and arcane or esoteric knowledge
that people are willing to pay higher
salaries for that
i think one of the things that we'll
learn today is that
it's not magic it's not
something that is inaccessible to
our audience members here it's something
that they can aspire to
as a career and take advantage of of the
reputation and the mystery around it
yeah what
what what are the responsibilities of a
machine learning engineer then
before diving um we hear you typing so
maybe you can mute
um if if you if i'm i'm talking that
that's oh yeah i'm sorry from the typing
okay
um yeah so important question i think
from what other responsibilities and
i think that makes it clear as well that
it is something that's reachable for
everybody
but it takes an effort so it's not like
it's
you're getting there in in just a few
weeks but if you
put your sense and your mind on it you
can definitely
going for it so it's probably also not
not
um unsurprising to hear that machine
learning engineers there are scarce
giving the lack of of
talent and also the current demand
demands very high
and i want to explain why it is such um
challenging but i think valuable field
so machine learning engineers must
cultivate
a very robust skill set and this
includes
programming languages excellence math
skills
but also the ability to comprehend
theoretical concepts into statistics
and in computer science so they they
must be
proficient in transforming models that
might only work in a very specialized
environment
into powerful scalable systems that are
suitable for functioning
in the business environment so
everything what you do has
tremendous business value but also
tremendous business impact
so that's why it is so so important and
machine learning
engineers responsibilities they're going
to vary depending on the specific career
role and then the specific
industry there are many different use
cases where you can support it and
depending on the use case the
responsibilities and then skill set will
differ
as well which um i think we will go into
it
a little bit later as well but generally
you're going to be helping organizations
to scale their ai
into repeatable into a stable and into
a dependable process where it's
it should focus on the outcomes that
that are desired for for the use case
that's defined so you might be working
closely with
the model ops professionals for example
who handle the post deployment
performance of the models and the
operational continuity
because it's an end-to-end ai process
demands
data integration it demands ai and
also a companioning software across the
full ai lifecycle from the design
to the and then the testing to the
deployment and the monitoring
as part of a machine learning
engineering responsibilities will be
working
with these other skill sets so that you
can ensure that tai
applications that are from high quality
that are performing well
and that they consistently deliver what
they need to deliver
so some of the skills that you probably
need is python
is c plus plus is mathematics including
calculus
statistics linear algebra
all which are frequent requirements for
organizations that
that will ask for these type of roles
and you also need to gain machine
learning and neural network skills in
order to help to discover solutions to
specific business challenges so machine
learning algorithm skills
they're equally important because you'll
be building algorithms that allow
a machine to identify patterns within
programming data
and to train itself how
to self-learn and how to think
autonomously
with the machine learning algorithms so
a few other responsibilities i think
what you can expect if you are a machine
learning engineer
working with algorithms or performing
computations
but also making programs more efficient
and more effective by pinpointing the
problems
that need to be fixed also helping data
engineers
to develop data and to develop model
pipelines
leading software engineering and
software design projects and possibly
explaining processes to
other business users also to the leaders
and the stakeholders so communication is
is important and the way you communicate
and simplify
your messages and make it understandable
for
also non-data
related people also analyzing and
extracting insights from massive complex
data sets and choosing the right
techniques
techniques to deploy this so it's it's
quite some responsibilities
um that's more let's say of a
generalized breakdown of
responsibilities that could apply
to many different circumstances but to
get a little bit more
technical um let's pretend you're a
machine learning engineer and you're
leading a high technology company so
your responsibility
your responsibilities they probably
might include
working with other teams throughout your
machine learning
high performance computing and your
autonomous system development
to generate the new the new capabilities
that you have defined
in your use case another example is
creating
scalable machine learning processes for
autonomous systems
and sharing all the phases of
development from ideation
totally to the deployment but also
integrating
entrant life cycles for distributed
machine learning systems
is an important part
and we have training assessing
debugging deep learning models as well
as improving
your distributed cloud gpu training
methods for for deep learning
models building tools and services to
enhance machine learning systems beyond
modeling options
like data quality augmentation or data
distribution
editing but also discovering and
deploying
new technologies to enhance the
performance and the sustainability of
your machine learning systems
so this should demonstrate how demanding
machine learning
[Music]
machine engineer responsibilities are
and the specifics of what you
can expect to find out in a real world
business environment so your
responsibilities
they are going to require soft skills as
well to ensure that you're able to
maintain
the pace with the complexity and the
evolution of the machine learning
in general so you have to expect to be
able to to manage your time wisely
to communicate effectively not only to
your team but also
to other internal stakeholders
research you have to do your research on
your own you have to be well organized
and methodical
and but also understand and process
different kinds of business knowledge
so you can quickly develop ideas so it's
if you're let's say um sum it all up
it's it's quite a package
from let's say what what type of
responsibility you have but as mentioned
every organization is organized
differently and you can share your
responsibilities as well and you don't
have to be the lead in in
in day one um and also if you look
because of the chief purpose um is to
connect
model building and statistical aspects
of the data scientist
with the development of the
production-ready ai and machining system
and platforms and services so you can
expect to collaborate with all these
other teams
and if we look to most of the careers
they will expect to communicate with
data engineers with data architects with
data scientists with data analysts and
and with the administrators but that's
more in your your own team in your own
department um the other part is to
communicate with the business and
with the ite teams like sometimes sale
teams or or
development teams so quite some
responsibilities but as mentioned it's
something
yeah that you can grow in step by step
and work on this responsibility step by
step so it's not something there
what you you get as responsibilities
from from day one
so hopefully um there's some clear
overview of the different
responsibilities it's a broad overview
as to what but
i think i mentioned most of the aspects
which are important
i'd say great um so
this uh slide also we'll talk about
you're
about to talk about a question that's
come up uh
in the q a as i've been following that
number of people been asking about the
need for
programming skills and which programming
languages are important
and so
when somebody is moving into a machine
learning
engineering role what are the skills
that
they're going to need to acquire and
maybe comment on
what skills they should have as their
planning for it
what are the kinds of
prerequisites that one should have and
what areas should one um
look to acquire as preparation for
getting into this role
yeah good good question and probably i
can expect indeed that
many asked this this question because um
it's it's the foundation it's defining
what what you want to learn what you
need to learn
and how to define your your educational
path so
if you decided you want to become a
machine learning engineer
how do you do it basically so maybe
let's start with
computer science and with coding
learning coding languages is the way
to start such with python for example
and with our
for machine learning or statistical
purposes
or sql for data management
we can hear you typing sorry
so if we look to the the basic level of
computer science related educational
that helps with the concepts such as
algorithms
like sorting and searching or data
structures like graph trees and stacks
and you also have to consider learning
machine learning algorithms which which
fall into
supervised and supervised and
reinforcement learning
i think this this is um important area
and an important foundation and this may
involve
linear and logistic regression k
means clustering decision trees for for
example to give you a little bit of
an id um so data
is going to be an integral part of of
your work as a machine learning engineer
so you have to choose to write data sets
and representation methods
and you have to understand the data
structures but you also have to learn
how to organize how to manage how to
access your data
so that's let's say one part with
regards to
to the coding then we have the math is
similarly
intertwined with many data science
fields including machine learning
engineering
and it may require statistics
multivariate calculus
linear algebra so you use the mass to
choose machine learning algorithm for
your data
or to set your parameters since the
machine learning models are derived from
statistical models
and having a solid foundation and
understanding of mathematics
will go along the way so let's
briefly talk about neural networks
neural networks mimic the human brain by
using algorithms
that are composed of input outputs and
weights
and a bias so they're used to predict
outcomes in decision-making processes
and they show
how making single changes affect other
network neurons and i'm bringing this up
because it's important to start
understanding the terminology
and the lines of thought and the
potential points of reference and
density
and also we can segway and talk about
deep learning later on so deep learning
is
is part of many great innovations with
ai such as natural language processing
or image recognition or
autonomous vehicles as well and it uses
large amount of data and it requires
more computational power
also with high performance computing so
deep learning
technology the the frameworks like
tensorflow or like pytarch
they're going to be an integral to your
work
as a machine learning engineer so
tensorflow has
many built in machine learning
algorithms and data sets
and it has kiras which is one of the
most used deep learning frameworks as
well
and then we have pytorch it's very
intuitive
and and great for research
more so than than it is for for
production so if you use python as a
programmer you will probably find
pytorch more simple to use but
tensorflow has
more coding languages to to support and
so if we look to pytorch was created
after tensorflow to create a more
intuitive
alternative to tensorflow but tensorflow
was
soon updated to accommodate
popular pi torch features so you could
say that
both the functions similar are modeled
after each other in in many different
ways so to
to summarize from the data science side
expect to
obtain skills like sql python
or java or other programming languages
but these are the main one
also data modeling probability
statistics
math hypothesis testing and machine
learning algorithm development
strategies
i think that's important part and on the
software side
software engineering side you need the
skills
in data structures like
multi-dimensional airways
graph stacks skills in system design
and you also need the knowledge in
computing
approximate algorithms complexity
as well as computer architectures like
caching clusters
for example so this is i think from a
technical perspective
um the skill set that that you need
which is the foundation for let's say
your career path and for your
educational path as well
stuart
excellent that that gives a
good overview but also it answers a
number of the questions that are coming
in through q a
um so
how do you become a machine learning
engineer
what is the what is the the
both the educational path but also the
career development
good question especially i think for if
we look to the audience
where not many people are a machine
learning engineer yet
or maybe hardly anybody
so if we look to the higher education to
becoming a machine learning engineer you
need a bachelor or even a
master in fields such as computer
science
or in statistics or in mathematics
machine learning deep learning neural
networks and computer vision these are
the
main areas where you can either do your
your
bachelor's or your master and there are
many online educational resources
available
to get your professional certification
and of course you can can think about
simply learn who can really help help
you out in in this direction and getting
you started
and then this is great because um
you have lessons that are created by by
expert educators and by professionals
who actually
work in the industry and you you can
replay courses and your lessons
and you can improve your studying and
you can do it at your own
pace so if you look to certifications
that are available that
prove your knowledge in a particular
subject and and skills
and these are great to add to your
resume
in order to gain the interest of these
employees
that really are looking for for the
machine learning engineers and further
extent
and customize you can further extend and
customize
your education as well and you can even
i think
take specific courses that are relevant
to certain requirements that you find
from potential employers you can get
different
certifications including machine
learning ai or data science
in all variants various different
kinds of capacities or in specific
fields of your study and where you can
dive more into for example reinforcement
learning or personalization
or what we just mentioned already in in
tensorflow
um so building your own machine learning
projects i think that's also a great way
to learn
how to become a machine learning
engineer which you can do in your own
time in your own pace
and you can practice your skills you can
learn all kind of new relevant
skills it's more trial and error
own-paced
type of education and gain more
experience and understanding
of the job requirements and and working
with yeah
with different um type of use cases
it can sometimes be quite difficult but
after pursuing the right education i
think and and learning everything that
you need
this is going to set you up for for your
future so building machine learning
projects includes
and then defining your problem statement
and you can also think about labeling
data sets testing
performing analysis of models but also
deploying and monitoring your models
and this is the most i think basic
explanation
about building machine learning projects
and
they are much more involved in let's say
technical and complex type of type of
type of projects
so let's say that you're finally ready
to pursue your your job as a machine
learning engineer at least that's what i
think you're
here for so you have your education
you have your your skills ready and you
actually have some
different options to to consider you can
become
a lead machine learning engineer senior
machine learning engineer
principal machine and engineer machine
learning software engineer
and there's also various different data
science rules
and this is just let's say a few
examples and if you look in
on the job sites they're all different
kind of
titles that are used and you can branch
out and find
the best role that fits fits with your
skills and
fits with your interest
you can also apply to different roles
and gain more experience and start to
tailor your skills
accordingly so just start a certain
direction
um see what you like and then
grow further just start somewhere and i
think it's
at least what was my experience um start
learning and
by by doing and trying to find out what
you really like
um and i think if if you're in this this
direction you should have advanced
degrees
and certifications in computer science
you should have
i think as well in math or in statistics
if you're going to to this this route
also can think about the master degree
in machine learning
neural networks and deep learning and
master degree
could be very helpful and focused at
strong
problem solving and analytical skills
and of course
yeah coding languages and working with
machine learning libraries and
understanding the data structures in the
data modeling so
let me let me break down what
educational skills and skill
requirements might look
like across the machine and engineers
careers
as they advance so for entry level
you might be expected to design and to
build models that
align with ai technologies so
you have to understand your organization
needs
from a business perspective and create
projects that they
that is this meet this type of needs
often designed by automated technologies
that introduce
more efficiency so you need an advanced
degree
in an engineering discipline in
statistics or in computer science
maybe even in engineering certification
can be
a direction and employers might require
that you have a master or even
a doctorate in a relevant discipline
the skills in maybe emerging
technologies
but also robust programming and
mathematical skills so you can build
algorithms and
they might also want to continuously
learn
new programs and new languages and to
improve your
your existing machine learning skills
so for a junior level position
you might have proven hands-on
experience at relevant
job for a few years two three four years
and expected to assume that more
responsibilities like
leading a junior team and assisting with
training a new engineering entrance
for example um yeah that's the path
where you can start
sharing your skills as well so you need
to demonstrate your expertise
probably in deep learning and machine
learning technologies
share them with with the others and the
ability to work in teams on specific
projects whether it's remote or whether
it's it's on premise depending
how you work if we look more let's say
to
for a senior position um you have to
demonstrate high levels of expertise in
data science high levels of expertise in
deep learning as well
as in machine learning frameworks and
the willingness to continuously learn
new skills
in ai machine learning as this this
domain is developing so
quickly so you can't sit still and
and wait and say hey i'm i have done my
education now i can stop
and i think you have to to provide a
demonstration of successful projects in
relevant areas and relevant areas
depends on
the industry depends on the topic and
it depends on on the type of models
i think that's that's a total summary
how to become a machine learning
engineer and then let's say
either junior or senior position says
stewart
great um and
that does address a number of the
questions people are asking about
you know how to get into this
this area from a starting position
how to get into this area from
experience positions in other areas so
we'll get into that in the q a um
this is kind of a silly question but you
know which industries
need machine learning engineers today
and you might
more easily say which engine industries
don't need
them yeah the the second question is
maybe harder transfer than the first one
and yeah so you see every industry where
data is used
you see this involvement and you have
some advanced
industries i mean in the tech industry
in
the healthcare industry and more some
laggers
maybe construction but as well there you
see quite some advancement
so i think the interesting part about
the machine learning world is that
they're still evolving on one hand and
that it's constantly changing
and yeah this is going to help you
um in an exciting career in a
challenging one and
find let's say your direction in the
field
um where you think okay where can it
help so
when you eventually start searching for
a job in this field
you might find the job opportunities
for applied machine learning um so how
many organizations describe machine
learning engineering
roles um so that's i think important if
you start
that not every industry describes the
role in the same way
and this helps to illustrate just how
new and evolving this field is that
it's not let's say a predefined role
it's not
terminology that's that standard so
machine learning engineers can find
careers in
basically any any industry that's that's
big on automation
that's big in big data and looking to
accelerate
more efficiency more accuracy of the
systems and of course everybody knows
the companies like uber or amazon or
spotify
or facebook or google or apple and these
are really the
leading organizations using machine
learning engineers to develop
interesting products and services
now if we look to the other industries
that are using machine learning
engineers
um there's some also some in industries
that are currently facing
more disruption and and then you can
it's not really an industry but
let's say it's a discipline if you look
things like
the supply chain supply chains are
continuously disrupted
right now whether it's pandemic or
ships in the sewers canal that that are
stuck
or any type of other reason
we see a lot of disruption in e-commerce
in finance in healthcare
in high technology these are really the
industries that
live in some kind of digital
thunderstorm
as i call it um and i think this this
isn't a coincidence these industries are
facing complex challenges
due to disruption they need to quickly
ramp up the digital transformation
or advance their current capabilities
by using the ai and
the machine learning but let's start
with with the supply chain
so if we look to the global supply
chains
they're very vulnerable so as i
mentioned not only from the pandemic but
also because of the trade wars the
market volatility
software breaches um critical
value supply chains has really
come into the spotlight since the
pandemic as
everybody noticed what's the effect if
your supply chain
breaks or if something is going on you
don't have your products or your
services anymore so these challenges
have demonstrated
how important machine learning is to
securing
your supply chain so organizations are
using ai machinery
to implement autonomous planning systems
they use it to use unified pricing or
demand optimization
but also you can think about raw
material recipe optimization
if your supply chain is changing and
certain
ingredients you cannot use you cannot
get
from your supply chain you need to
optimize
that based upon let's say what is
available and from which countries
it's available we see as well end-to-end
control tower transparency
so keeping up this overview in your
supply chain
optimized freight contracting um
is another big one and as you can
imagine routing and vessel sharing
in optimizing the whole transport flow
all of this is is difficult to actually
execute
um and and 60 of these projects end up
being later over budget that's what what
we see that's
some research from from mckinsey and
that means that this domain is still
quite
immature and machine learning engineers
are needed to help to
to productize the ai machine learning
and ensure that organizations can manage
broader supply chain value and then
manage the
issues better another industry which is
a one that's that's really developing
fast
which is in disruption is the financial
industry
so financial service organizations
they're amidst this
massive change and they're challenged by
research in all diff kind of digital
interactions that are leading to new
threats
um like fraud um synthetic identity
fraud
both attacks so that's something that's
quite hard to manage and you need to
really be on top of it
to to protect yourself to protect your
clients
and so federated models and supervised
learning models
and automated model optimizations are
being developed to help to combat these
threats via ai
machining driven solutions and platforms
but it's let's say not only the
organizations that develop
these machine learning algorithms the
the hackers do do as well so that's the
battle
between the two camps the good the good
and the bad
and these provide automated customer
authentication
um if you look to i think authentication
systems and verifications
but you can also think about other
systems like
automated case management systems um
smart fraud detection
um and now with the the cryptocurrency
you have compliant crypto
monitoring autonomous autonomous dark
web intelligence so what you see is that
there's many many many different areas
where you can dive into where you can
improve your skills and on one hand from
the business side from the algorithm
side
and you see that as a machine learning
engineer you can develop the models
for all these intelligent systems and
ensure that the systems are able to
continuously self-learn and accurately
identify all these suspicious patterns
and new activities
and which is a cat and mouse game i
think which which will
never end then we have let's say the
healthcare industry also developing
quite quite quickly
so healthcare institutions they're
drastically changing and streamlining
operations for the back office functions
um like using administration
administration-wide erp
systems to ensure the patient documents
and insurance information is updated
to making sure that nurses and doctors
and staff
that they can stay current on the
communication
and how and when they administer the
care for
for the patients so that's in healthcare
um
one important part is the operational
part the other part is the disease
potential prevention and the detection
of um analytical tools using big data
and they're being used to give
healthcare professionals the insights
into the factors that and that they
contribute to specific disorders or
what triggers particular diseases
but also who might be at high risk
for developing certain diseases so and
what you see there machine learning
engineers can help to optimize
these type of systems so that healthcare
institutions have the access to the
information that they need in order to
work
more efficiently and reduce the time for
analysis from doctors
and yeah save tons of money but also
improve
the quality and the last industry i
would like to discuss is the automotive
industry
um as you probably know the automotive
industry is expecting
a lot of value from data and then data
is is one of the
key areas where the automotive industry
can earn money
in near future
such as using vehicle data to predict
component risk
failure so manufacturers can better
issue the vehicle recalls for specific
cars and for models for example
and this can save the automotive
industry
really billions of of dollars i think
so we see that data is collected from
from sensors now more and more
on the vehicles and this also ties into
our
previous example that this data that's
used for analytical and
for anomaly detection so as a
manufacturer then you get
earlier insight into why certain
components
are failing or you can predict when they
will fail
and you can replace them already before
they basically fail
and and this improves the production
development
for these car manufacturers so these
type of software systems they are
created
they are implemented and they are
monitored by
machine learning engineers so you have a
very important role
in this whole process and everything
what you do has a huge
impact on the bottom line for for these
automotive industry
organizations and if i look to some
companies that have machine learning
engineering resources they even build
their own ai software for example
for for data extraction so you see that
automotive manufacturers they start
building
their own ai software because it becomes
the core of their
business i just want to add
as far as a career opportunity a lot of
machine learning
engineers they're going to be attracted
to
all kinds of let's say flashy innovative
companies
um with a very modern culture and
yeah this is understandable but these
type of organizations are usually
also um on the cutting edge and they're
able to provide
the higher salaries they provide the
better incentive that attracts
specialized and
um often let's say scarce
talent like the machine learning
engineer but many great
companies are challenged by pushing
transformation in ai and machine
learning forward
and with this current talent shortage
creating
let's say a higher salary bracket is
becoming even harder for these smaller
and maybe not so known not so flashy
type of
less innovative companies to acquire
these machine learning engineers skills
and
and people but working at the smaller
company
and helping them becoming data driven
and helping them to become
innovative to become an ai first type of
company
i think it can be very rewarding as well
and
as i gave you all the examples the
impact from your role
is substantial everything what you do
has a direct impact on the bottom line
which means
goes either profit or loss so your
impact for smaller companies can be
substantial
and if if i would let's say negotiate
um in such a role you can say okay how
can
maybe next to the salary you can get
some options or different kinds of
benefits from these type of
organizations if you
perform well and if you develop new type
of services that really
bring them great value because your role
is tremendously important for these type
of
type of organizations so i encourage
both let's say the prospective and the
current machine learning
engineering professionals not just to
overlook these type of opportunities
from these smaller
companies where you can really bring
great value i think and and bring an
impact
in in this company so i think
if we look to the different industry
stewards many possibilities
but you have to look for the
organization that
that fits what you like and
if it's basically basically what
what what you want to do
excellent and um let's let's move on
because we're
just about out of time and i know you
have a hard stop um
and you've talked about the roles
previously so let's do
a quick pull the audience 30 seconds
what skills are you most interested in
learning
um of the various skills here
which ones and you can pick more than
one
and when would you like to start doing
that
i've seen in some of the q a chat
comments that
we have a number of people who are
already enrolled and simply learn
certification courses in ai and machine
learning
and so congratulations to those folks
and leave this open for another
five four three
two one
and the poll results
uh not surprising that machine learning
is the most popular choice
followed by ai and data science and
a substantial number of folks want to
start right away
and that's always a good choice so
um we don't have time for a lot of
questions but let's
ask a few
right now my screen has gone dark
for a moment while it refreshes
one question that i've seen from several
people is that
they have a number of years of
experience and another field
control engineering or in business
administration
or management and
they have two concerns one is is it
difficult for somebody uh at that level
of their career to move into machine
learning and
is there any resistance um to people of
a certain age
becoming machine learning engineers so
if you
address those yeah i think um
if you are totally have if you have a
total business
background um i think it's it's smart to
start in in some kind of junior position
junior data scientist junior
data analyst to to get acquainted um
start
your education um maybe you can
start with a degree in in science
um maybe even an internship and it seems
like
doing a step back but if you have
both business experience and then
especially if you have it in a certain
industry
and you can prove you're either
having a data science study or you have
already a data science degree
and you start as
let's say a data scientist or junior
data scientist or data analyst
maybe even you quickly can learn
and from there you can define okay how
much
how many how much program skills do you
have
what can you develop what can you learn
do you have certain
limitations in this you can
find out what kind of math skills you
you have
[Music]
from there i think it's it's the best
way to find out
what is your best role and i see
many people making the switch and then
moving more to
some kind of team lead role um instead
of let's say maybe
moving to machine learning engineer or
to a data scientist but if you have this
combination
on one hand you understand the business
which is crucial for organizations
and if you're let's say used to some
kind of business role
often you can communicate very well with
the business
and if you then also can communicate
with your data and data science team
and you can translate this and you can
think from the business and define
what needs to be created from a business
perspective
that's where the business value is and
that's where you are some kind of the
bridge
between let's say the business and the
data science team
and have a quite unique proposition
compared to maybe even the machine
learning engineer or the data scientist
so
maybe if you're totally have no
background
take a step by step approach and then
see
how you can move along and how you can
basically develop your career and see
where your limitations
are but on the other hand also see where
the opportunities are
um within an organization and i think
that's
there are plenty of opportunities that's
where is a big
demand for organization and we haven't
discussed it today because we we're
totally focusing on the machine learning
engineer
but it is definitely something uh
whereas a huge demand
within organization for these these type
of roles
so yes you can that's i think the answer
but
it's quite a root and it's um
hard to predict upfront if you have all
the skills
but if you go that route there are
plenty of opportunities for sure
in in different type of type of
directions
i i see it's um at least
1830 of over here stewart
as mentioned i have a hard stop i'm
sorry about that
are you still there
i think we lost you stewart
so stuart not coming back i really would
like
to thank everybody um and i
advise you to to have a look at the ai
you're back
to have a look at the ai and machine
learning courses as well
and take a look at the simply learn
different type of courses for machine
learning
for ai and see which
route and which career path fits
best with you thank you very much um and
i will take over from
here ronald i'll let you go thank you
apologize for that
and um if you all bear with me
i will um as we say goodbye to ronald
and thank you for his time
i'm going to um i'll leave this computer
on
so yeah
okay
and um unfortunately we don't have
time to address your questions of which
there were very many
um because of ronald's hard stop
i'm going to try to coordinate with him
afterward to get an email out
next week that will address some of
these questions but in the meantime
i wanted to thank everybody for being
here today
and i have a couple of last
announcements
and
we do have uh certification courses um
yeah most in machine learning and also a
postgraduate program in
ai and machine learning in partnership
with purdue university
uh you can visit that at the
um
address that's on the screen
our partners sorry
i want to thank our partner
freshersworld for helping us today
and fresher's world is part of the team
lease
group of companies helping
freshers find their first jobs but also
team lease has other portals for
people in more senior positions so
please do
check them out um
and if you are interested
in digital leadership in general
management
in entrepreneurship um
in startups we'd ask that you
join us next week or two weeks from now
i should say for
a fascinating webinar
with professor jag sheth of emory
university
and he will be speaking about um
what the ideal profile of a digital
business leader is in 2021
and whether for example a be an
mba is enough for people to
manage a digital business
these days what does it take to become a
leader
and how does one develop into a
leadership role
so i've dropped the link for that into
the
chat window i do want to drop the
information about the two
courses both the intro onto
machine learning and as well as our
comprehensive
postgraduate program in ai and machine
learning and those are both in the chat
window as well
and i want to invite everyone to
connect with us on our social media
channels on facebook
twitter and linkedin which all
will find us at simplylearn
and thank you all for being here today
again i will try to get an informational
email out next week but for those of you
who have been here
throughout this uh webinar today um we
will be sending out
proof of attendance certificates uh over
the weekend
and um we will be also sending out
before that a link to the recording of
this session
so thank you all for being here and we
really appreciate
uh your time your interest
and look forward to seeing you at
additional
simply learn webinars
you